there seems to kind of i guess be a
misconception that you guys are going to
be in some type of salary cap hell
because you are using uh some some
different strategies to construct these
contracts like voidable years can you
just kind of clear that up a little bit
and
you know how much work is going to need
to be done in the future with your cap
situation
well there there's some corrections that
you're gonna that are gonna have to take
place
at some point down the road but it's not
good we're not in a position
we're not putting ourselves in a
position where next year we have to
release a lot of good players um we're
going to be in good shape
if we continue to just make sure that we
that we make smart decisions and we do
things right
we're going to be you know competing for
for years to come
yeah as long as tom brady's there look i
got no problem with them going all in
and putting themselves into a future
salary cap problem potentially because
they
wanted to win as many championships as
they could
with tom brady on the team whether it's
two years three years four years however
many years
we're seeing plenty of teams this year
kick the can into future years because
of the drop
in the salary cap that's what's prompted
a lot of this voidable year stuff
because
whatever the cap is 2022 2023
2024 it's going to be higher than it is
now so if you can take some money
this year and push it into future years
and those dollars don't inflate
so a dollar this year means a hell of a
lot more than a dollar next year in the
year after in the year after because you
can have a lot more of them to spend it
makes sense it makes sense and for the
buccaneers
who went all in seemingly for 2020
and it worked still have the window open
to stay all
in for 2021 why wouldn't you do it
you're operating on house money at this
point you've got a super bowl
championship even if you failed this
year
you still got one from the tom brady
experiment so i i fully support it i
i fully expect they're gonna have cap
issues later but i just
i just don't think you should care i
think that's the true answer we don't
care we're going for it now shireen
yeah the bucks are worried about this
year and they're worried about next year
because
that's the window right that's that's
the given window now maybe brady who
turns 44 in august plays even
longer than through 2022 but that's what
they have right now they have this
year and they have next year to try to
win another super bowl or two more super
bowls who knows but they've put the team
back together to to be able to do that i
have no problem with that
if the if they get in salary cap hell in
the future which i don't know that they
will with the cap going up as it's going
to go up but if they do who cares
you've gotten your super bowls out of it
i guess my question for the bucks who by
the way are going to return all 22
starters is the first time a super bowl
champion's done that since 1979
but i guess my question is when did they
start looking for that franchise
quarterback the next guy the guy who's
going to replace tom brady is it
something you do
again i think you go all in this year so
i'm not sure you spend that 30 second
pick if there's a quarterback you like
there i'm not sure you even do that this
year
but when do you start looking for that
guy
who's going to be the next tom brady do
you wait till he's gone or do you do it
over the next
couple years mike and let him learn
under tom brady
and of course the parallel was last year
when the green bay packers had a great
team
and opted to draft the replacement
eventual potential replacement for aaron
rodgers
in the form of jordan love but the
difference is the packers had real needs
elsewhere on the team the buccaneers
don't they have the luxury and that's
another topic that jason light addressed
yesterday with the media
of looking for players who maybe will
need a year or two to develop
quietly and behind the scenes because
they don't need them on the field
this year or next year because they have
all their starters
back and you know you said something
there sharing that i i can't
i can't let pass because there's
there was a a nonchalance to it that is
a reflection on how good the buccaneers
are right now the fact that we could
throw out the possibility of them
winning
three in a row something that's never
happened before
but wouldn't that be the ultimate
off ramp for tom brady to to
this year become the first team since
2003 2004 to go back-to-back a team
quarterback by tom brady and then
for his final act as an nfl quarterback
he does the thing that has never been
done before
and likely will never be done again
three in a row
three for three it's ridiculous to even
entertain the thought right now
or or is it is it ridiculous to even
consider the possibility that next year
at this time
we're gonna be talking about whether or
not tom brady has enough gas left in a
soon-to-be 45-year-old tank
to make it happen one more time and then
walk off into the sunset
i don't think it's crazy to have the
conversation when you've got a super
bowl champion
that's bringing back 22 starters and
went from seven and five
to eight and oh as they got better and
more comfortable
and more effective as they got to know
each other and they began to gel
all those guys are going to be together
again this year
i don't think it's a bad thing to have
the conversation and when you have tom
brady you have a chance right you have
hope
that that's what he brings to a team and
we we saw it this year
but how hard is it to do that
this time last year we were talking
about the chiefs potentially winning
two in a row and maybe three in a row
and it didn't happen
and the chiefs themselves were talking
about hey i want to win
seven super bowl rings we have a team
built to do this
and the chiefs found out what tom brady
long has known
winning one super bowl is hard winning
back-to-back
super bowls is harder and it's going to
be harder for the bucks they're gonna
face some adversity this season they're
gonna have some injuries that they
didn't
have last year you look at how healthy
they stayed last year
and how covet-free they stayed and
that's part of the reason
they won the super bowl so they're going
to have some adversity they're going to
have to go through
but we can certainly have that
conversation because when you have tom
brady
i do think you have to consider that
possibility because he is that good he's
the goat there's a reason he has all
those super bowl rings seven of them now
and counting and even though things went
stunningly easy for the buccaneers in
the super bowl let's not forget
they had to thread some needles they had
to sweat out some games
to get there the game at the saints the
game at the packers
you know it reminds me a lot of what i
was saying last year with the 49ers when
kyle shanahan made the comment of you
know what are you what's your goal for
this year what are you trying to do
we want to try to get back to the point
where we're up 10 points
in uh you know in the in the second half
of the super bowl we want to get back to
that point well that's
finishing that is the easy part and you
failed the hard part is getting there
and a lot of things have to go your way
they're going to have road games this
year with fans in the stands
so if they don't earn home field
advantage in the post season
the next time they go to new orleans in
the postseason it's going to be louder
it's going to be harder to operate they
go to green bay it's going to be louder
it's going to be hard to operate
this was the year that was taylor made
for a wild card to run the table
2020. it's going to be harder to do it
again what but
but when you look at how they they
finally got it together after the buy
last year if they can come out of the
gates and that's what's going to be
important and that may be why bruce
aaron's recently said his plan for
training camp is to beat the s
h dash dash out of them and he said that
on a podcast
loose cannons podcast i believe you
can't
falter early you've got to rack up 13
and 3
12 and 4 and have home playoff games
because the next time you go on the road
in the postseason could be a held a lot
harder than it was the last time
yeah mike there's no question about that
not having fans in the stands certainly
help them especially
in new orleans and then in green bay but
you know that washington game you
mentioned that one in the wild car round
that wasn't exactly easy
tyler taylor heineke kept bringing the
washington back and bringing them back
and kept them close and
you always felt like tampa was going to
win but until the clock the time
ticked off the clock you weren't
positive that was going to happen
so that was even a tough game for the
buck so nothing's easy
nothing's given and they're going to
start back from zero going into this
year they're 0-0 again but they have a
better chance i think to win the
division this year
with drew brees gone from new orleans
and all the salary cap problems they had
the players they've
lost in free agency i think it's going
to be a little bit
easier path for the bucks to win that
division now it's a question of can they
get
home field advantage throughout the
postseason
and that's what makes the schedule that
is coming out mid-may
usually it comes out before the draft
but they're holding it this year because
they had to go back and do some extra
work with the 17th game added
that's what makes the configuration of
the games we know who
and where we don't know when you get
your schedule loaded up early with tough
games
and you lose some of those games and who
knows what impact that has on a team
that has that presumption
of being there in the final group of
franchises in january
or if you start off early or easy early
and you've got
games you can win and build some
confidence continue what you did last
year
that lays the foundation for the tougher
games down the road so that schedule is
going to be critical for all teams but
specifically for the tampa bay
buccaneers beginning with
the game that they host on nbc to start
the season
how tough of a game will that be will
they be 1-0 will it be on one right out
of the gates
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports